[Music]
we're just grooving over here that's
just a taste of what you can expect at
notoriety live starting at the end of
june we have the talented justin young
here to tell us about his new residency
and how he continues to keep jazz music
alive and fun hi justin how are you
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to have you here and i gotta say
you're you're playing you're talented
you're so amazing but what i love most
about you is you always show up with a
little sparkle so thanks for bringing
the fun to the show today
let's talk about this new residency that
you have notoriety is an awesome place
what can people expect well my band
features uh incredibly talented rhythm
section every month we invite a special
guest star so we kick it off sunday june
26th at 2 p.m with a special vocalist d
train who's had lots of hits and it's a
very dynamic show so anything can happen
yeah a little something for everyone i'm
sure and we were joking earlier i came
up with the the slogan putting the
pizzazz in jazz but
you really do that and let's just talk
about the importance of keeping jazz
music alive and fresh and you're
continuing on you know to to maintain
that legacy of the music oh it's so
important the saxophone is one of the in
my opinion the sexiest instruments
and um i've just so been so thankful to
have a great career in it i've had seven
albums released and have performed all
around the world from paris to detroit
and it's this instrument and the music
is
amazing to listen to so invite everyone
out come on out go to writing you've
really immersed yourself in the vegas
culture but you just went back to your
hometown of michigan and you received a
special award tell us about that i did i
received the hall of fame arts award
from university liggett school that's
where i graduate i went to high school
yes and
gilda radner was a previous alum so it's
a very distinguished award and uh
there's six of us that have um won it
some very thankful oh my gosh that's a
huge honor congratulations and you and i
met a little while back you play at all
different events around the city you do
private parties a little bit of
everything what do you just enjoy most
about performing for all different types
of crowds yeah like for instance tonight
i'll be at bellavita restaurant in uh
henderson at 6 p.m so come on down um
but yeah i it it's an amazing thing when
you can play music and get the reaction
from others uh music is like anything
else it's something that brings us all
together and uh it's it's just a joy to
see people out in the audience having
fun with it yeah it really soothes the
soul right it does
well you guys go to bellavita tonight 6
p.m i love it there and just having live
music while you're eating is just the
best thing ever and then be sure to
check out his residency starting at
notoriety on june 26 mark your calendars
it's going to be here before you know it
all the information is on your screen
i'm going to step out of the way and let
justin take it away wait until you guys
hear him play
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
oh
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]